[Music]
you mentioned the idea of out out
telogen s-- artificial app telogen
artificial intelligence the idea is
quite compelling it's quite unique and
new and at least from my view of a
stance point maybe you can explain it
sure what I was thinking about is why it
is that we're waiting to be terrified by
artificial general intelligence when in
fact artificial life is terrifying in
and of itself and it's already here so
in order to have a system of selective
pressures you need three distinct
elements you need variation within a
population
you need heritability and you need
differential success so what's really
unique about software is that if you
think about what humans know how to
build that's impressive so I always take
a car and I say does it have an analogue
of each of the physical physiological
systems does it have a skeletal
structure that's its frame does it have
a neurological structure has an on-board
computer as a digestive system the one
thing it doesn't have is a reproductive
system but if you can call spawn on a
process effectively you do have a
reproductive system and that means that
you can create something with variation
heritability and differential success
now the next step in the chain of
thinking was where do we see inanimate
non intelligent life outwitting
intelligent life and i have two favorite
systems i try to stay on them so that we
don't get distracted one of which is the
ophrys orchid
subspecies are subclade I don't know
what to call it a type of flower yeah
it's a type of flower that mimics the
female of a pollinator species in order
to dupe the male's into engaging it was
called pseudo copulation with the fake
female which is usually represented by
the lowest petal and there's also a
pheromone component to fool the male's
into thinking they have a mating
opportunity but the flower doesn't have
to give up energy energy in the form of
nectar as a lure because it's tricking
the males the other system is a
particular species of muscle lamp
bacillus in the clear streams of
missourah and it fools bass into biting
a fleshy lip that contain its young and
when the bass see this fleshy lip which
looks exactly like a species of fish
that the bass like to eat the the young
explode and clamp on to the gills and
parasitize the bass and also lose the
bass to redistribute them as they
eventually release both of these systems
you have a highly intelligent dupe being
fooled by a lower life-form
and what is sculpting these convincing
lures it's the intelligence of
previously duped targets for these
strategies so when the target is smart
enough to avoid the strategy those
weaker mimics fall off they have
terminal lines and only the better ones
survive so it's an arms race between the
target species that is being parasitized
getting smarter and this other less
intelligent or non intelligent object
getting as if smarter and so what you
see is is that artificial intelligence
artificial general intelligence is not
needed to parasitize us it's simply
sufficient for us to outwit ourselves so
you could have a program let's say you
know one of these Nigerian scams
that writes letters and uses whoever
sends it Bitcoin to figure out which
aspects of the program should be kept
which should be varied and thrown away
and you don't need it to be in any way
intelligent in order to have a really
nightmarish scenario of being
parasitized by something that has no
idea what it's doing
you